ça c'est une rhétorique qui vient de la
gauche que longtemps la gauche a utilisé
de gauche contre la droite contre la
droite et comme soeur de gaz
incapacitant pour intimider la droite je
pense qu'on ne devrait pas surtout des
des membres de notre famille politique
je ne sais pas encore s'ils se
reconnaissent que membre de notre
famille politique mais on ne devrait pas
utiliser ces procédés d'intimidation qui
viennent de la gauche de la vieille
gauche d'ailleurs donc laurent wauquiez
à aucun moment à aucun moment n'a parlé
d'un accord avec le front national il
vient de rappeler il ya quelques jours
que c'était pour lui une île rouge tant
il à dire je ne ferai jamais d'accord
avec le front national
l'impression vous savez que c'est le
sparadrap qui est du capitaine haddock
là celui qui lui colle à la peau à
chaque fois on ressort vous pour lui
pour vous si d'ailleurs quoi parce que
je pense que en france on n'a jamais
supporté une droite autrement que
finalement soumise à l'hégémonie
culturelle et idéologique de la gauche
andré siegfried ya bien longtemps disait
ça il disait une droite moderne c'est
souvent une gauche ancien voilà donc
effectivement laurent wauquiez a une
ligne qui assume clairement un
positionnement idéologique et je pense
que c'est plutôt pour être vraiment
degré et j'observe que et j'observe que
avec emmanuel macron on parlait tout à
l'heure d'économies on voit bien que il
essaie de marcher sur les plates-bandes
économique de la droite si la droite
n'était que la réponse à des problèmes
économiques il y aurait plus d espace
pour elle je pense que il faut que la
droite puisse répondre à la double
angoisse française le déclassement
économique à travers le chômage de masse
l'ascenseur social qui est bloqué mais
en même temps la dépossession culturel
avec des notions aussi bien qui touche à
la civilisation au cadre national et il
veut y répondre et c'est pour ça que on
dit mais il est trop à droite
en réalité il a une ligne qui est salie
et on verra bien puisqu'il ya une
élection qu'elle lit va l'emporter à la
ronde et il est trop à droite
dans les rangs et leur en parle de
christine le monsieur estrosi
mais également il ya gérald darmanin
pour qui le pêché ça a été de ne pas
savoir choisir entre marine le pen et
emmanuel macron au second tour de la
présidentielle vous même par exemple
est-ce que vous vous sentez visé quel
était votre
choix en anjou on admet on était mais on
est toujours été clair y compris
d'ailleurs laurent wauquiez en dix ans
pas une seule voie pour madame le pen
donc les choses étaient claires
simplement monsieur d'armes avoir dit
oui c'était l'abstention mais parce que
mais parce que dans un certain nombre
pour un certain nombre de nos électeurs
prononcer ce mot c'était contribué
justement à l'est indiquent alizés parce
que pendant des mois il avait fait
campagne contre eux il fallait d'abord
dire ma rage contre le front national
et on a tous été très très clair
maintenant ce que je veux dire pour
monsieur d'hermann à quelques autres ils
sont les instruments dans les mains de
monsieur macron pour déstabiliser la
droite